Hello, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're the Slow Mo Guys.
I've always been interested in how
fire spreads against a sort of
solid, horizontal surface.
Yeah.
And like, you know, if you like throw
a bucket of petrol at a wall or something.
Yeah.
I always thought it'd be cool to look
at fire from the other side of that.
What, like, so as if it
was like see-through?
Yeah.
Like glass?
Something like glass, yeah.
Like this glass?
Yeah.
Not the first time we've
done that joke, is it?
No.
So, if you throw a
bucket of petrol on fire
sort of right here, hopefully in lovely,
glorious 4K slow mo, we'll see the fire
spread all throughout
and you'll be able to see
it against like a flat,
perfectly in focused surface.
Oh, yeah, that's a good point.
It's going to be perfectly in focus
'cause it's a level plane.
It's going to be like a cross
section of fire, isn't it?
Yeah.
It should be lovely.
And incredibly dangerous.
Please don't do this at home.
As you can see, we're
not at anyone's home,
we're in a quarry.
Yeah.
We've done this in someone else's quarry.
Okay, dangerous experiment so
precautionary measures are in order.
Getting the danger suit on.
So it's like flame retardant overalls,
flame retardant balaclava, goggles,
flame retardant gloves.
All for just a little bit of petrol.
Is it enjoyable wearing this
on a 37 degree day in Texas?
Hell, no.
Eyes here.
I'm gonna be positioned
there with the camera
zoomed in enough to fill the frame.
That's about as far away as I can be,
because it's gonna be night email
and then we've both
got fire extinguishers.
You're gonna use yours on the window.
I'm gonna use mine on the window.
Well, not necessarily the window,
but all of the other stuff
in case we need to-
Like the
flammable cardboard.
Pretty much.
In case you need to do another shot,
so I'm gonna get straight in there
with the fire extinguisher
and put it right out, to
stop any sort of flames.
And my fire extinguisher's
gonna be for you.
I'm gonna drag that right
close to the camera.
And I'll run in and put you out,
just in case it all goes wrong.
If I haven't put myself out already.
Yeah.
Yeah, I need to pee as well,
so we've also got that.
So, order of runnings.
You're gonna light it,
you're gonna throw it.
I'm gonna bag the camera.
Yeah.
Then you extinguish the cardboard
and if you're on fire,
I run in and extinguish you.
Before anything else.
Oh, I was gonna have lunch first.
You ready?
Ready.
Just gonna dump my hands in this water.
Okay.
Okay, I'm ready.
I'm gonna go ahead.
All right.
Here we go.
You good?
Yeah, we're good.
Get the camera.
Good?
Go for it.
Part of it, the glass.
Nice.
Excellent.
There was no splash back on me.
That's good.
But I would've liked to have thrown
it a bit higher on the glass really.
'Cause it dropped faster
than I was expecting.
Well, at least fire goes up.
It's true.
It's not like it fell on the floor, is it?
Like, the main part of it,
I think the meat of it was in the middle.
Careful, this might be on fire
and we might not be able to see it.
I've put it out I think.
Okay.
From the beginning of
Watchmen or something.
I look very menacing.
It's looks like I'm
throwing the fire at you.
That's the idea, isn't it?
Oh, yeah, look at that .
Look at that fluid.
Then, blast it, when
does it hit the glass?
I wonder if we can tell.
Oh, look, there's twisting water.
Yeah, they're cool.
Oh, there it is.
Whoa, whoa!
Whoa, that looks sick!
Wow!
'Cause that's all against the fire,
that's all one flame in focus right there.
Yeah.
Like it's not actually
coming towards you anymore.
It's cool.
Wow, that's actually really cool.
Isn't that?
I'm happy with that.
That's really nice and obviously
a complete guess on the exposure.
You nailed it.
It looked like it all held.
Yeah, you nailed it.
It's very yellow in the middle, but-
There's a bright moment there.
Yeah, what is that?
That's 1,000 frames a second.
180 degrees shutter.
Oh, what is it?
An F8, so that was a bit of a guess there.
Well, I think the brightest part is also
you see where the petrol is still liquid.
Yeah.
It's like reflecting the sunlight
and that was really bright.
Yeah.
Look at all the petrol suds
just on fire now.
There's like suds of petrol.
It's like the worst window cleaning ever.
Okay, cheeky bonus shot.
We're just waiting for the sun to go down.
So it's .
Sorry.
So, it's much, much darker.
It may not look darker to this camera,
but to the phantom it's almost completely
pitch black against that glass.
So this'll be a fire only version.
Bloody hell.
It looks a lot more when
it's nighttime, doesn't it?
Yeah, it does.
Well, I don't think I've ever ...
This won't do, will it?
I mean, I suppose the
joke about the window
doesn't work when-
You can't see through it?
When you can't actually
see through it, no.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Love it.
Oh, it's actually not
really worked that well.
Well, I don't think I've ever seen fire
from that angle.
Just to see the liquid splashing
and flowing onto the glass
with fire through it,
a sort of fire behind it.
Yeah, it's weird how it really goes
to show how petrol isn't actually
on fire as such when it's the liquid.
It's the vapors that are really on fire.
Yeah, but with you know
temperatures like this
and with it expanding and a bit
getting spread through the air,
it gives off those vapors like crazy.
It really does, doesn't it?
Like it's just impossible for
it not to all be on fire at once.
Should we just lob a brick through this?
Lovely stuff.
Hopefully you enjoyed that video.
Make sure you subscribe
to the Slow Mo Guys.
We also have a second channel
we've just put a video
featuring Linus tech tips
where we added 130 terabytes
to the channel's total storage.
So hop over there and bong that a watch,
if you'd like.
We'll see you next time.